let me uh read you a Reddit comment that
received two likes
two whole people liked it yeah two
people liked it uh
and I don't know maybe you can comment
on whether there's truth to it but I
just found it interesting because I've
been doing a lot of research on World
War II recently so this is about Hitler
okay here's it's a long it's a long
statement I was there when a big push
was made to fight bias at Wikipedia our
Target became getting the Hitler article
to be Wiki's featured article the idea
was that the voting body only wanted
articles that were good PR and
especially articles about socially
liberal topics so the Hitler article had
to be two to three times better and more
academically researched to beat the
competition this bias seems to hold
today for example the current list of
political featured articles at a glance
seems to have only two books one on
anarchism and one on Karl Marx surely
we're not going to say there have only
ever been two articles about political
non-biography books worth being featured
especially compared to 200 plus video
games that's the only topics with good
books are social ISM and Anarchy uh
would do you have any interesting
comments on this kind of so featured how
the features are selected maybe Hitler
because he's a special uh he's a special
figure you know I love that I love that
no I I love the comparison to how many
video games and that definitely speaks
to my earlier as like if you've got a
lot of young geeky men yeah who really
like video games that doesn't
necessarily give get you to the right
place in every respect
um certainly
um
but yeah so here's a funny story I woke
up one morning
to a bunch of journalists in Germany
trying to get in touch with me because
German language Wikipedia chose to have
as the featured article of the day
swastika
and people were going crazy about it and
some people were saying it's illegal has
German Wikipedia been taken over by Nazi
sympathizers and so on and it turned out
it's not illegal like discussing the
swastika using the swastika as a
political campaign and using it in
certain ways is illegal in Germany in a
way that it wouldn't be in the U.S
because of the First Amendment but in
this case it was like actually part of
the point is the swastika symbol is from
other cultures as well and they just
thought it was interesting I did joke to
the comedian I'm like please don't put
the swastika on the front page without
warning me because I'm gonna get along
now it wouldn't be me it's the
foundation I'm not that much on the
front lines
so I would say that to put Hitler on the
front page of Wikipedia it is a special
topic and you would want to say yeah
let's be really careful that it's really
really good before we do that because if
we put it on the front page and it's got
and it's not good enough that could be a
problem there's no inherent reason like
clearly World War II
is a very popular Topic in Wikipedia
it's like turn on the History Channel
like people it's a fascinating period of
history that people are very interested
in
and then on the other piece like
anarchism and
Karl Marx yeah I mean that's interesting
I'm surprised to hear that not more
political
books or topics have made it to the
front page now we're taking this Reddit
comment I mean completely yeah but I'm
trusting so I think that's probably is
right they probably did have the list up
no I think it's I think that piece the
piece about how many of those featured
articles have been video games and if
it's disproportionate yeah I think we
should the community should go actually
what's gone like that doesn't seem quite
right
um you know I mean you can imagine uh
that because you're looking for an
article to be on the front page of
Wikipedia
um you you want to have a bit of
diversity in it you want it to be not
always something that's really popular
that week so like I don't know the last
couple of weeks maybe succession the big
finale of succession might lead you
think oh let's put succession on the
front page that's going to be popular in
other cases you you kind of want pick
something super obscure and quirky
because people also find that
interesting and fun so yeah don't know
but you don't want it to be video games
most of the time that sounds quite bad